everyone was going on welcome to another
Python tutorial series this series can
be dedicated to tkinter and the making
of gooeys or graphical user interfaces
so first of all what is tkinter well if
you couldn't have guessed from what I
just said it's a module within Python
that helps us make Windows and really
what it is it's a wrapper around TCL /tk
and what TCL is its own sort of
programming language it's really a
graphical user interface toolkit like a
development toolkit
so what tkinter does is kind of wraps
around that and lets us actually use
Python instead to create our windows and
goobies so when I first started to learn
how to program I thought they'd like you
know every program was a GUI right I
thought that that was like the essence
of a program was because every program
I'd ever interacted with was GUI right
and so or so I thought it's not the case
but so I thought and only to later find
out that actually most programs are
headless in the sense that there is no
graphical user interface all so gooeys
are useful when we create a program that
we want to the whole point of the
program is to make the users life easier
and so a GUI is easier for a human to
interact with than something that's
headless so for example what we're going
to be doing in this series is we're
going to be creating this this program
here now it might change significantly
as we as we go through the series this
is where the program is now and what it
is is it's a it's a trading application
for a training Bitcoin now if you don't
know anything about Bitcoin and you
don't have maybe any Bitcoin or an
account with any of the exchanges that's
absolutely fine you won't need any of
that to do this series the data is
completely free to acquire and I'll show
you guys how to do that and then some of
the data like historical data is also
for you to acquire but we're actually
going to be getting it via sea of BTC
which is my Bitcoin website so and
that's free as well you don't need an
account or anything like that so anyway
that's that so you won't need anything
crazy to do this but I wanted to do this
specific application because developing
tkinter applications is a serious task
now it's not to say that that doing it
via Python is worse than any other
language so a lot of people just kind of
dismissed ich into right away
and I've even had people like flame me
on reddit for suggesting T concerted
people it's just because people are not
familiar with it and it just seems
really daunting to like create a real
application with it so like basic
applications let's see I think I have
yet so here's like a really simple code
that creates you know tkinter basically
and so you run it and up pops just a
blank window and then we can you know
later populate this window and all kinds
of stuff but for now it's just blank and
so that's some basic tkinter code but
then as you you know go on this this
code here is I think like a thousand
lines of code or something that creates
everything and so the idea of this
application is like I said for trading
Bitcoin but of course um like here we've
got just a mat plot Lib graph and we
want to be able to have first of all
this graph to be live and it is live and
so for example we can bring up like
btc-e tick data so btc-e is a Bitcoin
exchange and what this graph is doing
basically is every I think two seconds
on tick data it's querying the server
just to see if there's been any new
trade so right now there's not any new
trades just yet and then obviously we're
plotting up the buys and sells for
Bitcoin then down here is volume
pressure label volume and price but we
have not so anyways that so then we can
change the time frames and you see we
get new time frames and you can change
the intervals of the you know bars so we
could say we want one-hour bars
something like that so it's you know
much lower granularity there and also I
wanted to be able to add like indicators
and stuff like that so like the relative
strength index and then we can say yeah
we want 14 period something like that
and then we can do the same thing to the
bottom indicator we can add like MACD
for example and then we can still change
you know the open high low close stuff
so it's say let's change this to 15 it's
going to be a lot of data probably too
much data but that's okay so you've got
the MACD down here RSI here and
and you know we maybe add some other
indicators like simple moving average
we'll just take the default there and
then we'll also go ahead and add our
exponential moving average as well so
those get you know thrown out here so
that was the idea we wanted to add
matplotlib to tkinter so we could kind
of customize it a little more add our
own options and then also we wanted to
be able to do trading so this is this is
actually connected to one of my trading
accounts on btc-e again you won't need
it this is just an example but what is
shown here is basically the trade
history for that account and then the
open orders currently on that account
obviously we can cancel them and then we
can also make new orders by either you
know we could do market in which case
price doesn't even matter we call so
have limit and I'd like to be able to
add like stop-loss trailing stop loss
that kind of stuff execute the trade of
course and we got close here the other
things I'd like to be able to add is a
automated trading and then as well as
quick buy and sell so automated trading
would be like a even a simpler version
than CoffeeScript
like a lot of user just basically click
like I want to trade on the crossover
the 50 moving average and a 30 moving
average for 15-minute bars okay
something like that so that would be
automated trading then also quick buy
quick sell these aren't developed yet
either but the theory is you would set
it up and say like basically you want to
make a market order you would put the
pre you know amount in and then also
won't have to do to execute a trade it
would be very quick for them so they
would just hit quick buy or quick sell
and it would buy or sell the preset
values and then it'd be also nice to tie
that to like key presses like you know
control s control B or something like
that
and get instant buys and sells finally
here we've got pause and resume the
reason for that is with matplotlib ever
it was since it's a live graph every
time I updates it's gonna like force us
to zoom out I haven't figured out how to
stop it from doing that so if you're
zooming into the graph for example like
say we want to zoom in here eventually
when this this updates so we've zoomed
into a really specific spot when this
graph updates its gonna show us out
right it's gonna give us like the full
graph again so maybe it'll do that in a
little bit and meanwhile I'll just keep
talking on the other stuff so there it
goes so then also so that was an update
right it
you updated the data so anyways and then
finally we have helped in the tutorial
the idea years is to help the person
live through the application there's
nothing here
it's just you know it's not supported
yet and not supported yet and then the
idea here was just have a simple you
know pages part 2/3 and all that so
that's the idea and what makes it really
hard is at least for me when I jumped
into this was you know how do you even
the most basic thing like how do you get
to this screen and they're like get to a
starting screen and then maybe change
the window so in the sense here with
like trade and we'd say um you know we
want to do manual trading that brings up
a new window for us so that's not really
that difficult right to bring forth a
new tkinter window but what is difficult
is to change the things within the
tkinter window or to even have a
separate tkinter window now like this
application for example let me open up
another instance uh this application we
want to have a warning kind of in the
beginning that says hey this is a beta
application I'm not responsible for
anything that you know screws up
basically and we want the user to just
be able to say agree and then it takes
them to a new page and doing that is
actually really difficult there's a lot
of code that's required as a baseline to
be able to do this and so just a really
fundamental thing and and I don't see
anybody covering that so I thought you
know this is a huge issue I think more
people would use tkinter if they knew at
least had to do that those like really
basic things
so anyways that's what I'm aiming to do
here in this series is to teach you guys
how you can make this client you might
not care anything about Bitcoin or
automated trading a Bitcoin but it's
just a real world you know practical
example of what we can do with tkinter
you can do a lot of stuff and so a lot
of people's argument against tkinter is
really a Python argument they're saying
Python isn't the right language right
well the problem with that is TCL is the
right language we just have a Python
wrapper around TCL basically and so TCL
fully capable pythons fully capable so
the problem with Python is that it's a
single threaded application so it's not
going to use everything and each process
that it
going to undergo it's very it's a linear
right so it can't do multiple things at
once or natively it can't do multiple
things at once so if one task is taking
a while you're going to notice some lag
in the application that's kind of
annoying to the user
so that's like peoples main complaint
against this application or using
tkinter with Python but you can thread
Python you just have to do it after the
fact and that's really no different than
any other programming language you have
to do that and you have to be very
explicit and how you want to do it so
whether it's in python c java whatever
you have to do that already it just so
happens that in python it doesn't force
you to do that
so some people are sloppy and they don't
do it and in fact we have any I haven't
threaded this application yet but we'll
cover that anyways down the road that's
just a big a big task to do but to do it
in let's say C to write this application
C or say let's write this application in
Java it would still take far longer
right because Python is so simplistic
the syntax is easy to understand and all
of that so anyway I just think if you're
going to create a window it's easy in
Python plus I didn't really see anybody
doing it I thought it'd be kind of fun
and just a nice challenge so finally
before I conclude this video I just want
to say that this is everything here is
open source every step of the way
the code is posted on Python programming
net it may not be posted immediately
when I post the video but it will show
up eventually the code will be there
also you can always download it I'll put
the github in the description not really
sure if I want to put all the code on
github or just the most recent version
of course you could go through like the
historical edits you know so that might
be the only thing I do on github but
yeah if you want to look like per video
that we do on YouTube then you probably
go to Python programming dotnet also if
you guys have any it's completely
open-source so if you guys have any
additions that you'd like to make to it
suggestions or even just straight-up
code that you want to add that's totally
fine just submit it you can send it
probably to me you also probably do like
a push request or something on github
but we just send it to me sound the coax
I'm gonna have to look at the code
anyway there's always not malicious will
go ahead and add it in just take note
that that's interesting I remember
earlier price and volume we
showing that on one of the graphs I
can't remember which graph that was but
now I just noticed that volume and price
are there anyway um if you want to
submit code just know that it is it is
open source there's no like financial
incentive there if you want to have
proprietary code like I can imagine some
stuff for like automated trading some of
that's going to be server-side so people
won't actually have access to like the
code that's actually running the
automated trading so if you have
something like that you can contact me
if you want um we can maybe work
something out but we'll see the main
focus of this application though is to
be an open source trading platform for
Bitcoin so yeah if you guys want to
contribute please do just kind of just
make sure you look at like the most
recent version before you submit
something instead of just looking at
like where you are on the video or where
I am releasing the video but anyway
that's that if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions until next time